Hollywood is constantly filming bizarre
bits from space battles to magic spells
to NIC cages acting but sometimes the
strange stuff you find in movies are
there completely by accident he has a
look at five of the weirdest things
accidentally filmed in movies the
hanging munchkin during a scene in The
Wizard of Oz some viewers noticed
something upsetting going on in the
background a dark human-shaped figure
swinging from a tree as though it had
been hanged rumors soon spread that one
of the actors portraying a munchkin in
the movie was depressed over his own
work waited love for a lady coaster and
decided to hang himself in the Far woods
of Tin Woodsman set appears wonderful
however when MGM remastered and
re-released the movie in 1998 instead of
the hanging figure it appeared as though
a large bird was stretching its wings
some conspiracy theorists were convinced
there was a cover-up while others
believed a simple editing error somehow
made the bird appear to look like a
human corpse in the original version
this is what happens when you try to
look behind the curtain the Candy Man
slam who can smack a little girl in the
chin and get away with it the Candy Man
can apparently in the 1971 classic
musical adventure Willy Wonka and the
Chocolate Factory one of the extras
listening to the candy shop owners song
got an unexpected surprise when he
lifted the countertop to let the hungry
children through and accidentally
smacked her in the chin in the process
like a pro the girl didn't react but mam
that's still after her the mystery
spirit the ring is supposed to be scary
but here's a case of some unintentional
terror that the shadow person's head and
shoulders can be seen slipping in an
ounce of the lighted window frame behind
the characters in the sequence chances
are this was a simple case of a
stagehand being in the wrong place at
the wrong time with the mistake not
getting caught by the editors however
some superstitious fans believe it's an
actual spirit accidentally caught on
screen which seems to happen a lot maybe
even in this YouTube video
the missing masterpiece you wouldn't
ordinarily expect a family film likes to
a little too accidentally solve a
decades-old art mystery but that's
exactly what happened when Hungarian art
expert named Gergely barky spotted
Robert Barone's long-lost
avant-garde painting Sleeping Lady with
black VARs incredible name in the
background of the 1999 kids comedy bar
key immediately recognized it as a
masterpiece that had been missing since
the 1920s and spent the next two years
trying to get in touch with someone from
the movies production crew only to find
out there sold it off after filming
ended the collector who bought it later
returned it to Budapest 90 years after
it originally went missing and sold at
auction in 2014 for two hundred and
twenty nine thousand five hundred euros
makes you think huh I'm sticking the
painting and dancing the frozen children
Will Ferrell might have been trying to
trade in his slapstick comedy shtick for
drama was 2010 everything must go but
there was a bit of unintentional humour
in the background of one scene with a
bunch of children suddenly froze in
place while the adults continued moving
and talking either the child actors were
told to sit still for the shot and
really nailed it or something but really
wrong in the special effects process or
maybe Laura Dern's character is slyly
casting some sort of stun spell on those
poor kids with a weird hand gestures
creeping them thanks for watching
subscribe to our YouTube channel to
watch more videos like the one you just
saw and as always leave us a comment to
let us know which movie accident is your
favorite
[Music]